little n where little n is the length of the input strings to F and Hereafter I'm going to let Big N be this number 2 to
the little n it's pretty common that people use capital letter like this to denote two to the power of the lowercase
version of that letter we're going to be talking about the number capital N quite a lot so this is just going to be
convenient and it'll help to keep things a little bit neater and again this notation holds for
the entire lesson now of course we can solve the search Problem classically by simply
iterating through all of the possible end bit strings in whatever order we choose evaluating F on each one of
them if we find a solution at any point we can stop but in the worst case we'll end up evaluating F on every single
input string so this requires n meaning capital N
queries we could choose to measure the cost of this computation in a different way not just in terms of the number of queries but the number of queries
represents the number of times we have to evaluate the function f and it's reasonable to expect that the evaluations of f will dominate the cost
C of this computation this is in fact the best we can do with a deterministic algorithm
and again this is in the context of the query model if we've queried every input
string except for one of them and F has taken the value zero on all of them so far how can we be sure that the last
string isn't solution and the answer is that we can't so we do need all n queries in the worst
case we could also use Randomness that can offer some very minor improvements such as reducing the
expected number of queries needed to find a solution when one exists or we could effectively trade correctness
probability for a reduction in queries but however you slice it we'll still need a number of queries that's linear
in N So classically speaking we need a linear number of queries meaning linear
in capital N Grover's algorithm is a Quantum algorithm for search that does better it requires just bigo of the
square root of n queries those queries happen in superposition so it isn't Magic but it
is a significant improvement over what's possible classically and this is what's meant by a quadratic
Advantage can this quadratic advantage of quantum over classical be turned into an actual advantage in a practical
sense probably not anytime soon but in the distant future who knows but even if
if Grover's algorithm doesn't ever lead to a practical Advantage for searching it is nevertheless an important part of
the foundation of quantum algorithms that's well worth understanding before we move on to Grover's algorithm itself we need to
talk briefly about so-called phase query Gates many Quantum algorithms in the query model are naturally expressed
using phase query Gates and we'll see that Grover's algorithm is a specific
example let's start with a quick view of ordinary query gates for a function f of
the form that we've been talking about the query gate UF is defined onst standard basis States as is shown on the
screen and for superpositions of standard basis States the action is determined by linearity and it's worth reminding
ourselves that from a Boolean circuit for f we can in fact build a circuit for this operation UF at a cost that's
linear in the size of the Boolean circuit the phase query gate for f on the the other hand which will denote by
the name ZF operates like this in particular this gate operates on
little n cubits as opposed to little n plus one cubits and it basically just automatically kicks the function value
into the phase rather than xoring the output value onto an additional Cubit like we have for
UF so if we think about what happens when we use phase Kickback on a UF gate
we're basically just implementing a ZF G we need a minus State and it costs one
evaluation of UF but we do in fact get the minus State back and we can use it for the next one if we want to or we
could just throw it away so that's what a phase query gate is now if we're just
given a phase query gate ZF and this is the only way that we have access to the function f then we can't actually
recover a UF gate but if we have a controlled version of ZF then we can
build a UF gate and I'll leave that one to you as an
exercise in addition to the phase query gate for the function f we're also going to need a phase query gate for the nbit
or function or in other words the function that takes value zero when it's given the l0o string and otherwise it
takes the value one and explicitly the way that zor works on standard basis States is shown
here on the screen this gate doesn't have any depend on the function f so it doesn't require
any queries and one way that we can build a Quantum circuit that implements this operation is by doing something
similar to what we did for the function f except that we start with a Boolean circuit that computes the or function on
n Bits And now that we have these Gates we're ready to move on to the next
section now we'll discuss Grover's algorithm beginning with a description of the algorithm we start by initializing
little n cubits each to the plus state or in other words we put these cubits into an equal superposition of all
binary strings of length n what we're going to do is effectively to steer the state of these cubits
toward a solution so it's intuitive that we start in this state because we don't know anything about the function f yet
at this point every string is equally likely to be a solution and that's reflected by the fact that these cubits are in an equal superp position of all
strings and then we iterate we repeatedly apply the grover operation which is really the heart of the
algorithm and I'll describe it in just a moment we apply this operation a total of T times where T is some non- negative
integer but this number isn't actually specified by the algorithm itself we have to choose T somehow and in the next
section we're going to talk about good choices for T but for now we can think about this number of iterations t as
being arbitrary and Fin finally we measure in the standard basis and that gives us a
candidate solution there's no guarantee that it is a solution but if we choose T well then
the probability to get a solution can be made large and here is the grover operation